well despite the pandemic the number of
people buying vacation homes skyrocketed
this past year
sean greer is the vice president of
sales and marketing at vikasa
he says they saw a 40 increase in sales
of vacation homes
they manage about 23 000 properties in
400 different markets
here's a look at their 10 best places to
buy a winter vacation home based on the
best cap rates the annual return on
investment and ideal locations for a lot
of outdoor activity and r and r
we've got big sky montana coming in
first place followed by poconos
pennsylvania
conway new hampshire rounding out the
top three vail colorado number five and
close to us the lovely big bear at
number six
big bear it shows up as number six on
our list it's a good return rate at six
percent
so if people are are looking to divest
into real estate
out of other assets like it's a great
investment um
so and mammoth lakes also showed up
which i know is a little bit further
away for
for you guys but another winter market
on the list
guys says the reason for the surge is a
combination of greater flexibility and
work environment
people willing to drive a few hours
instead of fly he also attributes the
surge to the super low interest rates
right now
he says if you're planning to buy a
vacation home the best advice is to
visit the area
not just in one season the most popular
but do it in the off-peak season
as well